Hey, it's me Destin. Welcome back to Smarter Every Day (SED).
So excited about this video
In the last episode of SED
I showed you my transparent potato gun,
at 3,000 fps during the day.
3, 2, 1
But this episode it's going to be the same transparent potato gun,
meaning we can look directly into the science
at night, at 20,000 fps.
Google up! Science is about to happen.
What happens, if I start the ignition of the potato gun
from the back?
vs. What happens, if I start it from the middle?
I always thought it would have worked better
if you go from the middle,
'cause you get even expansion of those gases.
But, let's record it in high-speed, and let's see what the difference is, between the two.
We'll go from the back first!
We got some potato juices in there.
3, 2, 1
(laughter)
It's like 9 o'clock.
Alright, let's see it in high-speed.
It's completely awesome.
We saw that it started at one end and went all the way to the end.
Now, I'm gonna take this, it's a grill-ignitor,
You can see the little zaps there.
I've got electrodes, set up in the center of the potato gun
and we're going to zap it from the center
and we should get a more even combustion, right?
So, let me hook it up and then we'll give it a shot.
literally.
Loading the potato gun again.
3, 2, 1
(laughter)
It doesn't get old!
Was that cool, or what?
Ok, so check it out, so this is my combustion chamber, right?
The first time I shot this thing, it was a flint-sparker on the end of this thing, right?
If I hold it, you can see a twist
and I get the spark.
What you saw on the second time - here are my electrodes that I told you about
going to hit this button you can see
down in there. Can you see what I'm
sparking right there in the middle?
That's how I fired that thing. When we
first start the combustion from the end
it's a wave
you've got an oxygen/fuel mixture that
goes all the way down to the combustion
chamber; when we start right in the
middle,
we start to expand, we start using that
fuel and using that oxygen, but we run
out of oxygen before we burn all the
fuel. We're going to shoot this thing
from the end, we're going to zoom in with
a high-speed directly on the combustion
chamber and we're gonna see if we can
see that flame front moving one
Mississippi two Mississippi three
Mississippi four Mississippi three two
one
Ok, before i show you the next slow mo, I
want you to understand that it has
enough information in it to provide for
several phd's ,so I want you to be on the
lookout for a couple of key things that
I find interesting.
#1 When the explosion moves
towards the closed off into the
combustion chamber, unless the fuel/air
mixture is just perfect,
sometimes you'll run out of oxygen and
have unburned fuel
this creates a compressed pocket of fuel,
that stays unburned until it turns into
a rarefaction and pulls more oxygen back
in through the barrel, to burn it up
#2 There's something that
happens in combustion chambers called
"sidewall cooling" basically the pipe
itself cools the gases down below the
combustion point, so it can't burn right next
to the wall
this leaves more unburned fuel and
actually counts for most of the
pollution products caused by the engine
in your car
The slow-motion you're about to see is
real. I haven't ran the speed, to make it
look more interesting,
It's just pure awesome footage. Straight
out of a high-speed cameras.
Watch what happens, as the explosion over
expands, the system has to equalize so it
pulls air back in through the barrel
,into the combustion chamber, which causes
that fresh oxygen in the air to meet up
with the remaining fuel and start the
burning process all over again.
It's a pretty inefficient way to burn a
fuel rich mixture;
so I think my original hypothesis might
be wrong.
I think it's cool that when the gas
squeezes down into the barrel from the
combustion chamber, it has to speed up so
that it can maintain the exact same flow
rate
One of the things I love about science,
is the ability to look at a complex
dynamic system like this and try to
understand every physical phenomenon
that's occurring, but equally important to
me personally is the ability to look at
footage like this and say "you know,
that's pretty."
To summarize, what we've learned tonight,
think about this: when you have a
combustion chamber
we've learned that it depends not only
on the localized chemistry or the
stoichiometry, the fuel/air mixture at
any point inside that combustion chamber;
it also depends on how its vented it's
really fascinating the dynamics of
venting a combustion chamber effect
directly the ability to create localized
pressures and rarefactions sometimes at
the end of the video when the add part
comes up you kind of roll your eyes ,because
you're not excited about it.
Well, this time is different, you see,
SED is supported by
audible.com and they have supported me for a
really long time and it's a really big deal
because it's kind of expensive to afford videos like this.
So, what I'm going to do is I'm going to
create an audible event so that you can
remember to support SED at
audible.com/smarter.
We're going to create the same flame
front that we did before, only we're not
going to contain both sides of it we're
going to vent one side
I want you to listen to this huge
audible vent and then we'll look at high
speed ready? 3, 2, 1... It's on fire!
If you want to support SED,
feel free to go to audible.com/smarter.
That's a very audible event, I hope you
agree, anyway they have tons of free
audio books.If you get a free trial at
audible.com/smarter
I'm super stoked that they have chosen
to support smarter every day for so long
they've been a very valuable partner and
I am very appreciative so if you want to
support SED directly go to
audible.com/smarter get a free trial
of audiobooks you're going to get
smarter and you're going to like it.
So there you go, I hope you feel like
this video on your subscription if not
that's it.
I'm Destin you're getting smarter every
day have a good one
(inaudible) i ... going at
watermelons. Yeah and I'm record in slow
motion
You are?
Yeah. Is that cool? - That's what they all say...
You don't do it at night too?
Is that all right? - It's your property, do
what you want to do on it. You do anything
you want to do over here! You ain't going to bother
me
I think it's time to go to bed